Donald Trump touts the wonderful state
of our union last night well Democrats
sat and scowled except for the
Congressional Black Caucus who wore
brightly colored scarves and shawls
presumably to celebrate the National
exuberance of the last year as we have
made America great again it was so it
was really nice of them to do it and
that's why I'm wearing my kuchi sweater
today I want to celebrate too I really
like this sweater it makes me feel like
Biggie Smalls
I'm small E smalls actually that's gonna
be my rap name so we're really fortunate
also to be joined today by Senator Cory
Booker for reaction he's gonna come
right on the show and it's a real honor
to have a US senator here to react so we
will get right to it then the strengths
of intersectionality why conservatism
doesn't matter
and finally guy fawkes dies on this day
in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
all right there's a lot to talk about
here some of you might have joined us
last night thank you so much if you came
and hung out with us at the State of the
Union stream party I'm still slightly
hungover from it we spent four hours
smoking stogies and drinking and
watching the State of the Union it's a
lot of fun dennis prager dropped by i
think you can still catch that on yeah
oh well you can't catch it on YouTube
because they shut us down halfway
through CNN fraudulently shut us down
and made a copyright claim on our c-span
stream The Young Turks was using the
same stream and that went up perfectly
fine so I guess you can't find it there
but look for it on Facebook or the Le
wire something like that it was a lot of
fun I'm glad that my headache is
subsiding because we all had a very good
time doing so to get right into it I
want to focus specifically on the
Democrat reaction to some important
moments from last night's State of the
Union and we're joined by Senator Cory
Booker so let's begin Donald Trump said
quote tonight I am asking the Congress
to pass legislation to help ensure
American foreign assistance dollars
always serve American interests and only
go to Friends of America not enemies of
America Cory Booker your thoughts and
that P okay since the election we have
created 2.4 million new jobs this was
bad halfway through the speech including
200,000 new jobs in manufacturing alone
after years of wage stagnation we are
finally seeing rising wages unemployment
claims have hit a 45 year low
african-american unemployment stands at
the lowest rate ever recorded and
Hispanic American unemployment has also
reached the lowest levels in history
Cory a reaction tens of millions of
Americans tens of millions of Americans
are working yeah tens of millions of
black Americans are working the lowest
unemployment rate in history hundreds of
millions of Americans generally are
working we have really wonderfully low
unemployment right now so surely surely
that must have made you smile I had
tears of rage okay whatever so after
introducing
whose children were tragically killed by
ms-13 gang members offering compassion
for their heartbreak President Trump
said quote tonight I am calling on the
Congress to finally close the deadly
loopholes that have allowed ms-13 and
other criminals to break into our
country we have proposed a new
legislation that will fix our
immigration laws and support our ice and
Border Patrol agents so that this cannot
ever happen again Cory come on you gotta
like that I hurt Trump said quote
preston's reverence for those who have
served our nation reminds us why we
salute our flag why we put our hands on
our hearts for the pledge of allegiance
and why we proudly stand for the
national anthem
I hurt president Trump said
yong-ho traveled thousands of miles on
crutches across China and Southeast Asia
to freedom most of his family followed
his father was caught trying to escape
and was tortured to death today he lives
in Seoul where he rescues other
defectors and broadcasts into North
Korea what the regime fears the most the
truth today he has a new leg but seongho
I understand you still keep those
crutches as a reminder of how far you
have come your great sacrifice is an
inspiration to us all I hurt Cory you
were like a broken record Cory thank you
for being here maybe we'll bring you
back later or something not on this guy
Kent isn't it not happy about anything
at least though and look forget Cory
Booker at least members of the
Congressional Black Caucus they were
exuberant I don't know if you caught it
you should have seen them they were
wearing these beautifully colored shawls
they were very big and bright because
there's mourning in it I'm sorry what's
that hold on one second I'm just kidding
oh oh okay I got Lee I got that wrong
they were wearing the Scholz cuz they
hate Trump they were wearing them
because they're angry about something or
whatever they were also wearing black
for some other protest thing or whatever
Democrat rep Al Green said I'm wearing
this to show my solidarity with the
continent of Africa and especially with
those countries that the president
demeaned defamed by indicating they were
s hole or s house countries wearing it
to show that solidarity until
but the president know that I disapprove
of his statements and his behavior I
totally misread that Democrats were
already wearing black to highlight the
me to movement then they added on top of
that the colorful scarves Democrat Rep
Sheila Jackson as she said quote I hope
it was a pointed statement to those that
will see this as a symbol of respect
she said she believes that her Kente
cloth was from Ghana
she believes that it's from Ghana she
doesn't know this is exhibit 755 million
of my central theory of the left that
the left wants the appearance of the
thing but they don't want the essence of
the thing they think that their sixties
radicals their their play-acting protest
they think that they're out there
they're in the civil rights movement
because they don't want to realize that
the civil rights movement worked and Jim
Crow is over and segregation is over and
black Americans have civil rights but
they don't want to admit that cuz that's
not as cool it doesn't look as good on
TV it's not as heroic we're in a
decadent and apathetic age but we want
to appear like we're are these wonderful
courageous people actually fighting
against something it's much nicer it's
much more luxurious to just pretend to
be fighting against something and to
actually have to go do it because when
you actually have to go do it you get
water hoses turned on you and you get
arrested and you get thrown in jail or
worse but now there's did you just want
to look kind of cool right there wearing
the Ghanaian garb they're wearing that
those show she thinks it's kanae and
they don't know if it is I think it's
gonna enter I think it means something I
don't know but they don't want to live
in Ghana
no one's no one's moving to Ghana nobody
wants to be in Ghana and that's where
it's so disingenuous when they hit
Donald Trump over the s whole comments
you know that he allegedly said at a
closed-door meeting he said that a lot
of impoverished countries in Africa and
Haiti are not very nice places to live
he said that mostly because they are
clearly not very nice places to live if
they were really nice places to live we
you would see Americans moving to live
there rather than all of them begging to
come to the United States they are so
disingenuous in in the act itself in the
conversation itself it undercuts their
own Arg
you can't simultaneously say those
countries are so awful this country is
so wonderful that we owe it to the rest
of the world to let people from crappy
places move to United States and also
those places aren't crappy and also in
simultaneous you can't no you cannot
have both simultaneously but the left
wants to have the appearance of the
thing and they don't want have to deal
with the with the essence of the thing
that which animates this activism these
ideas
this is slacktivism at its finest
they're wearing the black for the me too
they're wearing the Ghanaian thing for
protesting Trump for some other reason
or because he made improper comments
untoward comments on couth Commons
behind closed doors at a private meeting
what is next what are they are they
gonna wear a little pin for Kony 2012
what about just we Charlie how we're
just going to add ever it'll will have a
mosaic of faux concern and faux activism
and absolutely empty virtue signalling
and posturing here are two of the
greatest social media supporters of
Donald Trump two of the of only 45
people that he follows on Twitter I keep
trying to become one of the people that
he follows hasn't happened here they are
explaining the ridiculous parade well
that's what these look democratic
lawmakers do they sit down on the
American people that's right here we
have a president that wants to stand for
all Americans yes and you have these
Democratic lawmakers they want to sit
down on us but you know it's not gonna
be tolerated and see I think what they
want to do is take us back to the Jim
Crow days that's right they want to take
us back with their manipulate and
intimidate us and telling us how it's
going to be they want to hand us crumbs
it's we it's reminding me of that
president that said we're gonna give you
another I'll keep you quiet but not
enough to make a difference it's time
for a president to stand up and make a
difference that's what President Donald
Trump is doing and it's either the
Democrats can stand up or we can do like
we're trying to grant a path to
citizenship we need to grant them a path
to retirement it's time to retire some
of these Democratic lawmakers the
Congressional Black Caucus sat the whole
entire time will see these people are in
another they back in the 60s this is
2018 we are in a new era a new America
this man is truly making America great
again why wouldn't you be happy with us
having more money in our pocket a want
to hand you
crumbs we can no longer vote for a
system that's handing us crumbs anymore
we need to vote for a businessman that
wants to make this place great again and
I don't see how the Democrats are going
to get in and how they gonna win it in
2018 and how they're gonna win it in
2020 I love them so much I love them so
much and they're absolutely right there
they're thinking on this is so clear
because they they observe just that line
alone they're living in the 60s these
people are living in the 60s they
realize that it's to their political
advantage they are very lightly educated
basically everybody in Congress is very
lightly educated but especially people
that do ridiculous stunts like this the
things have changed there we're in a
different place we're in a different
culture and it's no longer there isn't
no longer an advantage to pretending to
be protesting for things that haven't
existed for 50 years so lest you be
tempted to think ever even in spite of
what diamondden self just said very
articulately very clearly lest you be
tempted to think that the Congressional
Black Caucus members who frowned and sat
in war coogee colors last night are
principled or politically admirable in
any way here they are here are members
of the self-righteous Congressional
Black Caucus including Barack Obama
smiling taking photos with Louis
Farrakhan the Nation of Islam leader who
is famously said quote white people are
potential humans they haven't evolved
yet they call them terrorists I call
them freedom fighters
Judaism is a gutter religion and Hitler
was a very great man language Fester's
Corey that is a great point as a first
good point Cory Booker made all day long
language Fester's now you might wonder
why you've never seen that photo of
Barack Obama with Louis Farrakhan before
that's because the media buried it we
already know that the media do this we
know that there was the journalist
conspiracy of major mainstream
journalists speaking to one another
conspiring on how to hide bad news about
Barack Obama and push a fluffy pieces to
make him more appealing this was run by
Ezra Klein who now has the audacity and
the gall to run voxcom and say that he
is an explanatory journalist he's
nothing but a cheap hack and a
propagandist he's been exposed
spectacularly
more than anyone else in the media he
was exposed for being a hack
propagandist and now he comes out and
says I'm the the adult in the room who's
going to explain things to you also an
explainer for Ezra Klein all journalism
is supposed to be explanatory that's
what language does but that's neither
here nor there Hillary Clinton tried to
make this louis farrakhan thing an issue
during the 2008 race she kept trying to
get Barack Obama to reject Farrakhan
support so you have to reject his
support Obama played coy the whole time
he said he denounced it but he wouldn't
reject it and he's trying to find some
distinction without a difference had
this photo come out Hillary Clinton
could be President had that photo come
out of Barack Obama and other CBC
members smiling with a hate monger like
Louis Farrakhan very likely he wouldn't
be president and she would be President
but it's still happening they're still
covering up for these guys it this
photos one of the reasons you haven't
seen it now is it was unearthed by some
kind of lefty journalists to the major
networks are not covering it Fox is the
only one that's covering it the rest
will not touch this thing you're trying
to down flow it they'll allude to it but
they won't cover it in depth because it
just doesn't it doesn't fit the
narrative and if it doesn't fit the
narrative they're not gonna run it not
to put too fine a point on this
Congressional Black Caucus members will
not smile at low black unemployment but
they will smile with a man who says that
white people aren't yet humans and that
Hitler was a very great man
that's the Congressional Black Caucus
imagine for a moment if there were a
congressional white caucus it sounds
absurd it would be absurd in fact
imagine that any white member of
Congress met with a white racist a white
purveyor of racial division like David
Duke or Richard Spencer or whomever
imagine the endless reporting imagine
the endless coverage they would be not
only run out of Congress they would be
run out of the country tarred and
feathered on a rail do you remember a
mean girl Jake Tapper
yeah grilling Donald Trump during the
campaign CNN employs that mean girl Jake
Tapper and he was grilling Trump do you
do you disavow David Duke meanwhile
Donald Trump said 15 years earlier he
said David dukes an idiot I don't want
to be associated with him at all I don't
like him he's terrible there's no place
for him at all but then for some reason
Jake Tapper just decided to bring this
up again because it was a good cudgel to
hit Donald Trump with so do you disavow
David Duke and Trump said what do you
mean David
David Duke from why are you asking me
these stupid questions these questions
that are basically akin to do you still
beat your wife do you either either way
you answer that you're you're
implicating yourself you're you're
defending against a harsh accusation
you're playing into it with any response
do you disavow David to exact dare you
associate me with David Dirk Obama
didn't get that treatment he didn't get
that treatment with Farrakhan a Donald
Trump you don't see photos of Donald
Trump smiling with David Duke hands
shaking hands thumbs up but you do see
that with Louis Farrakhan and Barack
Obama he met him he posed for picture he
smiled at him so the Congressional Black
Caucus will sit and scowl for record-low
black unemployment but they will smile
for a racist anti-american Haim longer
that's because they're charlatans they
don't represent their constituents any
of the constituents they claim to
represent pure charlatans they should
not be treated as representative of
anybody their district constituents
black Americans
none of them every Democrat who sat last
night for the American flag the national
anthem and low unemployment is a farce
and a fraud and should not be afforded
any respect as a political leader not
for one single second that said keep it
up guys
keep it up bring it on this was
excellent for Republicans Trump clearly
did it on purpose
he backed them into corners so when he
said we need to stand for our flag in
our anthem what he was really saying is
you I'm going to force you Democrats
into a bad photo op because they've
spent a year now two years now saying
that NFL players should not stand for
the flag so anything they do if they
stand up they're weak because they've
flip-flopped on their position on the
NFL if they sit they look profoundly on
American which they are and which they
did look like when Donald Trump walked
in one one thing to notice some we were
joking about it on the stream he was
himself applauding so he walks in and
he's applauding he's on the stage he's
applauding and this is really nice
people were trying to say that this is
narcissistic he's applauding himself
that's not what he's doing it's actually
exactly the opposite there are a few
things here there's a guy'll lessness
about this there's an innocence about
this he he clearly is new at being the
president and at being a politician at
all and you can see that he's a little
rough around the edges he doesn't quite
know he appears quite humbled by it but
it's also humbling if he
sinn he's walking in for the State of
the Union and he's applauding now what
one read is that he's applauding himself
but it didn't look like it he's looking
around he actually stepped away from the
podium before he began speaking he was
standing to the side and looking around
and clapping at everybody
this isn't like when true narcissists
like Bill Clinton or Barack Obama walk
in they feel like they're King Caesar
marching into Rome Donald Trump isn't
there - for the State of the Union to be
the Trump accolades parade it Adam
surprisingly it wasn't that he was there
to laud the State of the Union he was
applauding the State of the Union there
is a lovely humility in that which you
can only get from a guy who plasters his
name on every building in the world you
know there's a lovely irony in something
very American about it the guests were
great - a Donald Trump invited David
Dahlberg firefighter who saved 62
children and staff from a summer camp in
the California wildfires he invited
Ashlee Leppert a Coast Guard technician
who rescued dozens from the Hurricanes
John Bridgers founder of the Cajun Navy
to help hurricane Harvey officer Ryan
who lets a cop who was shot twice on the
job who adopted a child from parents
addicted to opioids corporal Matthew
Bradford who lost his sight and both
legs on a deployment in Iraq first blind
w amputee - reenlist in the marine corps
ever a staff sergeant Justin Peck he
saved a fellow American service member
from an AED in Syria
Preston sharp he's a young boy who
organized the placement of American
flags and red carnations on more than
40,000 soldiers graves Steve Stobbe and
Sandy Keplinger small business owners
how long has it been since we saw small
business owners lauded in particular at
one of these speeches corey adams a
welder a worker at stokes company for
parents whose daughters were killed
tragically by the gang ms-13 Celestino
martinez an ISO officer who hunts down
those gangs compare this to Barack
Obama's in 2016 Obama didn't invite
anybody the invites were a tradition
were started by Ronald Reagan but by
2016 Obama wasn't running anymore he'd
had enough of that he invited lots of
people almost every year 2016 nobody in
2015 the last year he did it he invited
mark Kelly
more Kelly as you might recall is the
husband of Gabby Giffords so the idea
was that Barack Obama invited him
because he was going to go on a mission
into space to prepare the way for
America to send a manned mission to Mars
that was ostensibly the reason that's
not really the reason mark Kelley is a
major gun control advocate and Barack
Obama was trying to grab guns for his
entire presidency Barack Obama began the
presidency by moaning all of those rubes
in the country who cling bitterly to
their guns and to their religion that
was the purpose it was a political dig
and an anti-american one at that Alan
Gross who Barack Obama took credit for
releasing from a Cuban prison as a way
to sell his total caving to the demands
of the Castro regime he was the other
guy that Barack Obama invited that year
you know a Trump gives invites and the
people to whom Trump gives invites you
know it highlights important aspects of
our country important sides of our
country
workers servicemen Sheriff
philanthropists patriotic kids victims
of crime that we have to address the the
Democrats held six state separate State
of the Union responses last night nobody
watched any of them I even we didn't we
were supposed to be streaming one we
watched twenty seconds of that Kennedy
kid drooling on himself we said we can't
watch this anymore
in front of a broken car presumably to
call attention to the fact that
Democrats destroyed Detroit so we turn
that off and we just kept drinking and
hanging out here is one short clip from
the celebrity organized people's State
of the Union
basically said screw it
he's been anointed head of the EB hey
he's suing him yesterday running the
show today since taking office he's been
a man on a mission to make sure we keep
increasing our carbon emissions he
doesn't believe in science
cuz he's painting Paul says the Paris
climate Accord is just a bunch of bull
there's a silver lining struggles then
we get a gift by these various struggles
and the one silver lining in Trump is
that we have created the mother of all
movements we have I think my face is
gonna be in a permanent state of cringe
so that last guy at the end was Mark
Ruffalo he's that a professional
protester who occasionally does
superhero movies or something but
previously you heard that awful singing
the lyrics were terrible they were just
rhyming day with day and they didn't
have a point and the points they made
didn't make any sense and it sounded
terrible these are supposed to be the
entertainers these are supposed to be
people to entertain us and they don't
entertain us they're not even when they
try to they aren't good they they're not
there isn't any proficiency or skill or
talent in any of this they were wearing
a shirt that said we are all dreamers or
something like that these people are
doing politics now because they aren't
good at art they aren't that great at
art if they spent a quarter of the time
that they spend ranting ignorant ly
about politics they spend a quarter of
that on their craft they would be much
better in that harmonica thing wouldn't
have popped out my eardrum okay I've got
my most important takeaways from the
State of the Union we've got much more
to talk about why intersectionality
really does work this is terrifying but
it is we have to admit it and why
conservatism per se doesn't matter but
first before we do any of them we got to
talk about these are
dangerous times folks and we have got to
talk about ring so I've talked about
ring a lot you've heard me talk about
their home security camera I love it
its innovative it's totally the 21st
century way so they've been sending us
actual footage of ring busting crooks in
the act this is one that I wanted to
share with you on this show so I'll set
it up a woman runs up to a porch to
steal a package from the doorstep and
then look at what happens hey put that
down I just stopped someone from
stealing my was she wearing a pink hat I
don't know looked like she was wearing a
pink hat so she runs up she's gonna
steal this package and then the guy is
on his ring app and he was talking to
her he said put my package down what are
you doing and then she just she doesn't
even acknowledge just puts it down runs
away into the car she got completely
cuts really unbelievable and and ring
video doorbell because we've heard these
stories there was a study in a downtown
LA somewhere at some neighborhood around
LA where ring gave out a bunch of its
product to a high crime area and home
burglaries went down by 55 percent in
six months so you hear these statistics
but here you actually it's Amberson and
it's very entertaining so I wanted to
show it it's a really effective way to
stop package theft because thieves just
cannot hide with a ring even if they try
to steal your ring the video is up in
the cloud so you can get him anyway the
look on her face says it all she was
caught red-handed she drops the package
runs away the ring video doorbell lets
you see and speak to intruders on your
smartphone from anywhere even share
video clips to your neighbors using the
ring app so if this little crook and the
pink hat runs up and presents to your
package you can say get out of here and
then you can share that video to your
neighbors and say hey watch your
packages we got a crook in the
neighborhood a rings flood light camera
is really good to spotlight cameras
really good they let you bring a ring of
security around your entire property
you'll know the floodlight cameras
that's when the derelicts you in my
audience will run unto someone's
property to break in or something and
then a light hits you and then you run
away that that's what it does exhibit
also has a camera and uploads all of
that to the clouds you can see it from
any
we're from a beach in Bali or your
office or whatever stop crime before it
happens
help make your neighborhood safer with
ring people used to do neighborhood
watches that was the old-timey way to do
things with mixed results this is the
21st century get with the 21st century
you know you're not going to chase down
the robbers and horse and buggy either
this is the way to do it now it's much
less expensive it's much easier you can
do it from anywhere you have to get it
you can save up to $150 on a ring of
security kit at ring.com / Knowles K
nowl
es just like the last name of jay-z's
wife KN o W Elias that's ring comm /
Knowles $150 off when you go to ring
comm / Knowles Marshall what is it
ring.com / Knowles okay the big
takeaways from last night by all
tangible measures the state of our union
is strong by all the tangible measures
militarily as a matter of the economy as
a matter of the the bureaucracy
shrinking as a matter of the judges who
have been appointed more a judges
appointed in this first year than ever
in history and they're all good original
ist's who are actually going to
interpret laws in the Constitution as
they were written all wonderful stuff
there was a lot of North Korea talk
North Korea victim was invited to the
event one wonders how much time a little
Rocket Man has it to live on earth I
really looked like the build-up to some
action that should have probably been
taken 25 years ago so good on him on the
intangibles on the culture we haven't
been this divided in at least half a
century maybe longer they're clearly no
they wouldn't stand up for America they
wouldn't stand up for the flag this is
weird people say Donald Trump is so
weird and so strangers President Trump
is like perfectly normal compared to
these people who are sitting for their
own country it's so disgusting and
outrageous all of that does show the
strength of intersectionality we've
heard this term bandied about
intersectionality is defined as the
interconnected nature of social
categorizations
such as race class and gender as they
apply to a given individual or group
regarded as creating overlapping and
interdependent systems discrimination or
disadvantage the word was invented in
by a feminist named Kimberly Crenshaw
it's such a fake term by the way that
when I was writing this out my word
processor put a little squiggly
underneath it that's how new this is I
don't might word isn't that old you know
but this is the strength of
intersectionality so you saw the illegal
aliens were a big political issue last
night nobody would care about illegal
aliens if not for intersectionality I'm
old enough to have worked on political
campaigns when it was a given when it
was on both sides of the aisle that
playing to illegal aliens doesn't work
for anybody because we don't want people
breaking our laws and the illegal aliens
theoretically can't vote obviously
Democrats are doing their best to make
sure that they can especially in my home
state of California but obviously it
makes perfect sense that no one would
care about illegal aliens as a political
matter because we're the voters we by
definition if only people who are not
illegal aliens can vote you wouldn't
play to that except for
intersectionality what intersectionality
does is create this hostile toxic
divisive a world in which you are
convinced you're brainwashed into
imagining oppression everywhere
everywhere among every person except for
whatever contrivance it's at the top
probably in this in this version of the
culture is straight white men who think
that they're men but if you're a man who
thinks that he's a woman that's okay you
get to go then you're one of the good
people and the only bad people are the
straight white men who think they're men
right up at the top and in that way all
of the division that you would have
among different groups say for instance
taxpayers and illegal aliens or American
citizens and illegal aliens who are
killing them and lowering their wages
and increasing crime and taking a lot of
welfare and lowering standards and
schools because a lot of them don't
speak any English and are illiterate
those groups might have had some
friction with one another except for
intersectionality teaching them everyone
has to get along except for the man
sitting at the top and it has clearly
worked the term was only going to 1989
just a few decades later it has
fundamentally transformed the Democrat
Party and fundamentally transformed
American national politics this is
really scary and we need to
figure out a way to stop it we need to
figure out a way certainly we on the
right should never play into these
intersectional games and tropes and
euphemisms but we really have to stop it
it is poison and it will only last so
long you can't erode the heart of the
American culture forever eventually it
will just collapse around itself
one last happier takeaway is that Donald
Trump is a good politician so here's the
line of the night my duty and the sacred
duty of every elected official in this
chamber is to defend Americans to
protect their safety their families
their communities and their right to the
American Dream because Americans are
dreamers too Americans are dreamers too
excellent line of the speech it was the
one that everybody remembered I think
Stephen Miller wrote this speech Stephen
Miller is wonderful with language he
went out a little long this speech could
have been a third shorter it was just
too long but it was excellent through
and through if he had just condensed it
a little bit more it would have been
great his use of language is superb
Trump delivered it very well he's
clearly a good politician and hit the
people who work for him or good
politicians because almost every line of
this speech was crafted to put Democrats
in impossible corners where they would
have to face their own anti-americanism
and look bad for the cameras and I'll I
to have one final take away this one is
an important one for conservatives I
started to mention this last night
during the livestream but we got cut off
by the speech so here it is
there is no conservatism without people
I see this a lot on Twitter people talk
about this and what about okay well this
is good the conservative governance has
been good in the State of the Union is
great and the speech the State of the
Union is great and the taxes are going
to better data but what about
conservatism what about the ISM is the
ISM okay there it there isn't a
conservatism absent people there isn't a
conservatism without time and space and
people this is a classic error that the
rationalists fall into sometimes talking
about rationalism and politics this is
the classic error conservatism
that first of all that that implies that
conservatism is an ideology and that's a
very modern concept that Bill Buckley
doesn't think it was an ideology Russell
Kirk didn't think was an ideology Edmund
Burke certainly didn't think it was an
ideology all the founders of what we
would consider conservative thought
modern conservative thought didn't think
this ideology is a formalized abridged a
rational sub thought of of the tradition
conservatism robots all of that we were
but the it we resist the age of
ideologies period so I wouldn't say that
I'd say the conservative thought
conservative coalition is a pulls from a
lot of different philosophies and views
of the world and importantly
institutions and traditions into the
tradition it pulls from all of that and
all value isn't fleshed all value comes
through men doing things that's oh
that's the only way that value has any
meaning in this world is in time and
space and through men doing things and
right now we have a government we have a
Speaker of the House named Paul Ryan we
have a vice president named Mike Pence
we have a president United States named
Donald Trump
we have cabinet officials we have the
Congress we have the Senate we have
Supreme Court justices and these are men
who are doing things they are the ones
who are doing and a lot of people are
attacking them for that because they are
the vessel of conservative thought and a
conservative agenda if it were different
people the Left would be doing precisely
the same thing and it is a huge mistake
for conservatives to attack them and to
pull away from them and not to support
them because they are doing our agenda
if they stop doing that if they betray
what we would like to do and betray our
agenda by all means attack them and find
a new vessel for those thoughts and
those ideas and those goals but while
they're doing it support them and do it
that this is it it's very tempting to
say oh you know I like conservative
things I like what Trump's doing but
he's icky and I'm much better than he is
but no he's the one doing it he is the
one affecting that agenda along with
Congress along with the Senate along
with that all of the judges that he's
appointing you should support that it's
that is conservative that is what the
conservative thought leads one to do and
you shouldn't be beguiled by rationalist
ideological and essentially leftist
ideas on how values relate to the real
world this is the real world we're doing
great things we're making America great
again so be happy about it and we're
exuberant colors just like the
Congressional Black Caucus because we
should celebrate ok let's get to this
day in history but first I'm sorry this
a good this day in history this is a
really good people don't know anything
about this did this day in this day in
history but I'm sorry you're watching on
Facebook and YouTube I'll have to say
goodbye to you now I assume you're not
watching on YouTube because CNN probably
took this feed down to and YouTube
probably obliged but if you're watching
on Facebook you've got to go over to
Daley wire.com Daley wired.com is where
you get me you get the Andrew Clavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro show you
have the conversation with Alicia and I
am going to be on the next episode so
you can ask only members can ask
questions but everybody can watch many
are called few are chosen
you also can send in questions to the
mailbag you also get no ads on the
website you got a lot of stuff blah blah
blah this guy's this is what you need
the State of the Union is strong and the
leftist tears are welling up I actually
I might need a second one just from Cory
Booker's appearance on our show today I
might need to catch all of those Cory is
just one of these guys he's just one of
these Democrats who are pouring out
salty leftist tears so make sure you go
over there at $10 a month $100 a year
and you get the only proven vessel to
capture all of the radioactive left is
tears daily wire.com we'll be right back